but it's the effort that matters from
2006 to 2010 2011 I answered every
single tweet and every single email it's
literally what I did for a living and
then the math beat me
it became unscalable I had children I
started to build another business which
is taking up a lot of my time but the
effort of that and the infrastructure it
came about me building what Seth Godin
would call a tribe and building
relationships with people that care
about what you talk about every time
something happens for example here's a
good story
my sister had her first child so I was
out of the pocket for two days because
that was an important family event
somebody during that time tweeted
garyvee you've really sold out I used to
be able to tweet you and you'd answer me
in a minute I've tweeted three times the
last two days you haven't replied to be
hashtag jerk me even though my city
listen this is what loving the
unscalable does me even though my sister
has a baby and I'm sending a lot of time
I'm paying attention to everything I'm
just not responding I'm trying to save
seconds I saw that tweet before I could
get in there and three was 12 minutes
old 700 of my fans dismantled that human
being hey [ __ ] his sister had a
child and all things that look like that